oh you want to undo this well we went to
get coffee and I said I'm gonna hold on
it started because I said did you see
that snake chin bring up my Instagram
Iceman you see that snake big snake well
hold on it's a Diamondback pit viper
Raunak yeah pit viper i had a legit
Western diet pathologist that's a lot
herpes
hey y'all excited and you were excited
about that you were in an excited mood
and I go what have you seen out there
and you said coyotes he said God has
seen mountain lion mountain let's see
okay I went and you went seen coyotes
mountain lions turned and walked and I
went you have stop for a second I go I
go what you say and you go I said did
you say mountain last and you go yeah so
my last coyotes is that like I go can we
have stopped again now look at me and if
you go you go well and I go
was it a bobcat and he goes might have
been a bobcat I don't know because they
look at you and they run away I go okay
I go so was it a bobcat or did you see a
mountain lion and you go
I didn't see about care about I did see
a coyote though I say you can imagine
what it'd be like so great but I didn't
see a large coyote and it was moving a
thousand mountain lion and I just
included all those animals you panned
out my pants but kovat will do but I
will tell you that first of all that is
the biggest most dangerous snake of
everything my life is [ __ ] so I'm
running right usually my son was me
thank God he wasn't with me during this
okay I'm running with my I listen to
loud music usually I'm logic right I'm
doing my thing I get my short shorts ass
cheeks out the back daddy's moving and I
just for whatever reason I like to vote
my left and I see this gigantic Black
Diamond rattlesnake and I go holy [ __ ]
and I freeze yeah and I take my
headphones off because I'm like it could
just be maybe a gardener it's the
biggest of all time right so it's not a
rat snake either okay so I take my
headphones off and I hear nope that's a
rabbit a California king snake that's
around inside well daddy's just gonna
run fast and because it's two miles get
back with us that way
why are you go back this way it's six
miles yeah I don't go back six months
calm exhausted third workout of the day
sure so I'm gonna beeline past a snake
and then I got the vision in my head
because I've seen too many snake
documentaries movies of that thing line
and you know faster Rattlers they're
super fast yeah and I'm not that fast
now and also I'm in the middle of
nowhere
daddy doesn't want to die you're going
down so you know what I did I turned
back around I turned back around with
another six miles he went six miles he
smells Wow
I was so scared should have called me
because I was said listen to me right
now I just face off do a big u-turn
around it and just keep going but you
didn't want it I can't because if going
the shrubs so check this out problem
yeah and there's be another one it's I
don't wanna do that I'd be surrounded
and there's mount lines and there are
mountain lives crouched that'll have it
seen but you can imagine what you can
imagine it there there so you got to
choose between mountain lion and [ __ ]
rattles so then it's with by Whitney's
house to go check out the stage just
hold on
coming old bands coming down like you'll
be careful there's a giant I sitting in
the conduct as I panicked so this giant
economist there's no in the currents
California way my bat it's a giant black
rattlesnake he goes where so Whitney
this old guy in the other coffee I lied
yeah on accident I panicked today on the
conic sure my brain wasn't working yeah
so then I go look I'll show you
I go down L snake he's not there anymore
Dante Dante check this out we're all
staring here I go yeah he was over here
and there you go where is yep I don't
know then I hid behind this fear and I
went see everybody push the old man down
and then [ __ ] push him down I didn't
push him down you push him into the
snake I did not actually get liked it
like that Steve on to commented that a
serpent brother stay back
thanks Captain Obvious here is that
snake check this out by myself I went
all right well I'm gonna keep going this
week his shorter path I'm gonna take
these small rocks not gonna hurt him
scare him yeah so I go hey else snakey
you're my world Papa the thick boys
gonna handle this I throw the rocks they
went like this yeah he there was a
person who wanted to kill it and they
don't man enough nothing the snake did
not nothing didn't didn't flesh badass
try giving by see what happens you know
hey fat ass do not pass go
he's been around since the Java guys
know it's been a real act $100 been
around since the Garden of Eden he's the
one who [ __ ] caused everything to
[ __ ] up in the first place he's the
devil he doesn't give a [ __ ] about your
stupid stones I heard an old man
somebody was gonna kill the snake the
old man said you're not gonna kill
he would not let anybody kill that snake
because that snake we're in his home he
said you know nobody's touching that
snake I like that old man yep because
he's right and he died today on that
mountain he died by that snake yeah by
that snake dude okay is that not the
biggest [ __ ] live rattlesnake you've
ever seen your life and he's Negril yeah
how crazy is that
that means black how crazy is not that
you don't want that I was so scared yeah
I was sixty sometimes you can get bit in
the leg and what'll happen is the leg no
longer works your leg no longer works
your leg dies happens to dogs all the
time oh and then they you alive yeah I'm
telling you I did not much spiders don't
scare me sharks don't happen to me
happened to me I saw a huge loss don't
scare that well I was skid that's more
non-cycling my son yeah I'm scared it
hits your it kind of in a primordial way
do you know that apes are terrified of
snakes so if you have a chimpanzee or a
gorilla and it's around a for any kind
of any kind of simian any kind of his
they see a snake and they scream and run
it's in our DNA that's why they think
human beings have a [ __ ] primordial
fear so you gotta peel sss phobia of
snakes they think it's a genetic memory
of when we were can i tell you this
because I've seen so many snake can't
just just catch them and then hold them
yeah it crossed my mind how cool that
would be to do for the gram you gotta
get behind it now that's a pit viper now
you don't want that's such a bad idea
oh it's such a bad idea because if that
thing hasn't bit in a while now
sometimes I don't know if you know this
Brennan but sometimes when a rattlesnake
has just eaten and it injected something
with its venom you might get a dry bite
believe it or not you might get a ghost
load and a large a ghost large
rattlesnake might bite you and give you
only a little venom because I don't want
to lose all there now bait now baby
rattlesnake you know why cuz they're
just like oh we have notes we don't have
any idea where's all my values all my
venom I kill they're more dangerous than
yes the growth that guy sold he might
just give you a dry bite as a warning
God don't don't and you got a little fan
out so I went hiking my son this morning
I and I sent him this video I said I
tell you we always look out for snakes
papa
he goes I know and he was let's find
that snake we're not looking for snakes
so do you see the video I posted now he
didn't give a flying [ __ ] about any
snakes and he was conducting business so
listen no turn this up Chen he's on the
calculator
okay well dang dude you don't seem too
busy to hike with your dad a lot of
deals going on yeah okay Dan sorry dude
sorry man okay I'll be quiet sorry do
you got it I know you're doing real
deals he's accusing of all time that is
the greatest video here's Moana calves I
didn't speak out get some Bourbons mama
not me I was the cutest thing ever fun
is that she's doing business steals dude
he didn't give a flying [ __ ] about the
snakes
I kept warning him you do Papa let's
find this thing kill it no really what
you talking about we're not gonna kill
it awesome I'll tell you this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]